this is a real this is a real this is no
rhythm overnight it's been a while how
do I remember what we were doing
yeah I'm kinda in the same boat I got
some stuff that should help us remember
though got a lockpick and then I just
wanted to go over some items that we've
acquired power cable wrench that looks
important a fuse
I think that Zach so those are like the
major things that I think we need to
start considering yeah definitely gonna
want the alright so you have the fuse
the machine oil and the power cable
those are the things you need to start
the tram but I remember correctly yeah
you have the touch of a fire hose thing
now a fire hose or something to
extinguish flames or the wrench maybe oh
yeah yeah okay sorry so you have you
have to take the wrench yes got it like
that health you look good go back
through again you might need a few
spaces because you are getting the fire
hose I could combine some is I got four
five aids which is crazy but I I am okay
I have for almost fifty bullets and
seven shotgun shells so I'm not in like
a huge rush here wait what would
combining aids do three of them gonna
give you grenade launcher around I think
it just makes me see you hot to trot I
don't understand what that means in this
context
I think it's this one yeah I think there
is I thought I made more no and cry day
with other things but you don't just see
is created with a a and B but I think if
you combine a an a well we're combining
a Naidu I think you just gives you more
anyway so says me where we going
yeah you're gonna go like east when you
come out I don't remember the map yeah
it's gonna be [ __ ] all right I think so
this is a restaurant I think you're
gonna go down through here mm-hmm
so or no wait go farther down so that's
where the we were here right that's when
we pissed
we like blew that thing up that was like
where the puzzle was mm-hmm okay so
that's the restaurant
have I gone through that part where
there's fire yet that's well that's what
we're trying to go oh dang and then
that's where I'm gonna put all the stuff
yeah alright so that's just that if you
go to the journalism building first
before the restaurant that's the escape
route from the journalism oh okay cool
alright so where am I going it's a good
question I think you're just going
soothe yeah I think you're just going
over here because you're going back
uptown or no downtown [ __ ] you're uptown
or downtown right now you're going the
opposite one you never heard the song
jukebox hero well not the way you sang
it I'm not sure if that's a testament to
my knowledge or your singing ability hmm
so all the way down I think you're
actually gonna go through that door
but check back this way anyone could
double-check that's okay
okay so that's this is the other puzzle
but we kind of solved this didn't we we
got this piece or whatever did you put
the yeah you put the book on the statute
did put the back book on and I got
something okay
so through the door I think so just
don't use your map it should show you
where uptown and downtown connect I'll
show you the door hero so we're in
downtown I don't know go to the next
layer the map you should be all there
keep going this way oh this is the
[ __ ] where's where all the liquors
were where I struggled so forward I
think so
well we're gonna learn a lot today
remember when I had a bad episode yeah
oh
okay let's talk about this - oh he's
gonna hit me by the time I would just
run yeah the Doherty right he's running
on his [ __ ] seat destroy him not so
sorry yeah I can't
he's eating my butt I got hurt we're
afraid to say out all right okay sweet I
think we're going the right direction
I got right hmm I think there was gonna
be two of them
I think you're going the right way I
think you're going back to the parking
garage and I'm not I know you're going
back because I know yeah you're good
you're good just go through here took a
lot of damage some blue herbs there but
you don't need no I haven't needed any
poison and stuff am i doing all right
give it to you no I don't do that one
was there believe I got that hurt all
right so take a long view and go down
there are nizam yeah they're coming
after me
[ __ ] you what so on edge ah that was the
most stressful thing that's happened so
on the right any songs
going the right way I don't know
no yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah go back
that was that was it right there yeah
okay we're good
how do you tell you to do it to me that
didn't sound good there's dogs I think I
hear dogs ruff ruff here they're little
little pitter-patter of their feet II
pause all right sweet okay so wrench it
up
this looks like a time for wrench
wrenching hit the map out quick as I
think all right uh what
all right see that say vroom the fire is
to the left so I need to go past the
dogs oh yeah all right so I should quit
my gun you think I can get rid of him
with a gun right yeah and knocks him
back in this game assuming a work they
were dogs and not those weird crawling
like dogs didn't they yeah what's that
noise what is that noise
I could mean anything
let me check the map out again alright
so check out I will check it out check
that dude's body as well if you have
time okay I think I already did but I
gotta hear it
knees together and back up here it you
look way cooler with that body vest on
now thank you
still look down oh [ __ ] probably dodged
that no screw him I'm gonna kill him
right let's do it
[ __ ] you there's another one he's clean
it's clear this alley is clear
uh-uh it seemed like a crab walk good
it's like The Exorcist look you [ __ ] I
[Music]
dangler looks like he says danger and
then points to the right I think it's
dead damn it I wasted a shotgun shell
yeah I thought he was coming after me
you saw it the door alright doesn't look
like a door
[Music]
we're in the right place I don't know
originally locked this [ __ ] all right
wait I want to let's do this again good
you can kill me if you want do you think
I don't know you a decent amount of ammo
tell you well I just don't know what's
coming up after the fire and I don't I'm
out of heels but oh if the guys gonna
come after me then yeah I do want to
kill them because I don't want to run
through zombies and that [ __ ] cuz
he'll kill me
so yeah dude am I going yeah good hey
you alright geez I wish I had a grenade
she said so many of them I actually
think a grenade will be perfect in a
place like that
alright so should I go into the same
room or no should I get health no I'm
sure to health I have no health on me
yes sure I don't know what your health
supplies like any saver I got some
greens man I got greens
got that good good I got some spray and
I got five greens and I got a red but
you were like Nick because you might
want to combine that with a blue one day
you have enough greens to combine it
with a red
do you know I'm saying cuz you were like
you really oh you might want to combine
that with our blues sometime yeah you
can combined those I don't think you'll
need green blue red
he says he looks away longingly combined
it's done is done
stores I've already killed
this looks like a place for a hose I've
already killed all the dogs is there a
very nice
got him smother the flames go back to
the fire world from whether you came
okay it's a new area
I lost my hose so now I go forward
mm-hmm for the first time this is
exciting new ground
[Music]
I'm just looking for goodies there's no
duties I thought maybe they'd be thick
like a little one what were you hoping
for red herb would have been nice let's
go forward we'll explore before we check
the map why checking the map is the
smartest thing to do in these situations
Oh which way do you want to go it's
about understanding your layout man also
there's a zombie right there and the
only pick goes up there probably there
for a reason I'm gonna pick up one okay
yeah I mean you've got to go back the
other way anyway ah Jesus stop it to
make sure
oh crap did you not see him yes um I'm
uh you dodge you dodge
try to mm-hmm or just blow them away
either one am I going that way your
business why you check them out they're
good you're right there by the double
door just hook a hook Oh Richard nice
that's why you check the map you walk
around you go where am I going
uh listen Emerson make me do this Murphy
I don't want to shoot you kill me
[Music]
everyone wants to date him wait wait
we don't have to do this yes we do have
to do this
genome
[Music]
one shot to the head probably would have
been alright way to make him suffer
Murphy no I know all the ladies loved
him
all these other holidays
he doesn't even acknowledge that you're
there there's ammo oh my god Murphy it's
terrible
there's handgun ammo cam I wish wait
wait wait wait go back go back go back
please allow me to give you some advise
some of the medicine in the storage room
are unstable and their quality will
deteriorate under changing temperature
or humidity therefore you must remember
time loads all over the place
temperature well there is it should be
advice you should personally check it
every day and then also that's that's
two words every day it's two words in
that case every day try and remember
that a machine is no more than a tool to
be used by people
maybe there's a point maybe there's a
point to those typos that I'm not seeing
if you forget the password to lock the
door try and remember that it is a word
that everyone is familiar with don't
forget that once a new product is
shipped the password will be updated
again you can always enter the password
from the terminal of the PC for
administration [ __ ] wait does that mean
I don't know wait what
I'm sold I'll go buy some shafts prin
that commercial got me it's safe sprin
in store now all right whatever
maybe saps offspring save spring is the
password what if it's cure maybe sales
overview for this quarter numbers are
high that's a really lazy report dude
who's in charge just literally wrote
sales overview for this quarter and
didn't actually I thought there's a
bunch of safe sprin on the corner there
yeah chug it the immune mmm well that
must be the computer Murphy wait wait
let me check Murph yeah give me some
shelves Murph don't be stingy I don't
want this fax liquid medicine named vtj
98 jolt I do remember of agile dude this
guy's got nothing I'm gonna be pissed
give me your freaking bullets you
butt-faced he's got nothing
he died poor yeah not a nickel to his
name this how many of the letters it was
instead it changes every time a new
shipment sent out so they also said it
was a common word go back and check
those things sorry do you want to try
something else read the business facts
and the wait yeah in the matter sport
wait are you going to fast what can't
you read okay
everyone is familiar with a new product
it's got to be the product that makes
most sense
so steps that's right why else would you
turn that TV when it's gonna be seven
shafts room do the remote one more time
to double-check SAS to be umbrella
sprin alright that's aspirin yeah sprin
[ __ ] yeah it was what you thought
I thought cure made more sense
just keep the temperature stable if
possible I don't know yeah I don't know
what that means
I don't even know how you would change
the like we can try it was like I can't
go in there I'm too hot this sweatshirt
on my ways makes me look wonderful let's
check out the map it's an L room high
temperature steam pipes okay
low temperature steam pipe also known as
liquid nitrogen mm-hmm that looks nice
oh my god I can't take all of it unless
what's your health at it's hot put that
balloon with you green red you might as
well I can combine those yeah you could
do all three in this game yeah
just marry [ __ ] in your mouth are you
sure that works
yeah doesn't ruin it bees baby baby baby
sure maybe that's to add to the machine
oil for that
I don't know cuz we already have oil
just add that to it all right so what am
I supposed to be doing here got the oil
additive maybe that's just one thing you
need for the tram right but why even
have this temperature thing then examine
the oil additive yeah I don't know
Yeah right so yeah okay like I could use
the crank on this I don't think so
the crank I think is before the trip as
well I just don't understand then what
am i doing
you're coming back here or maybe you're
gonna yeah
[Music]
shoot the pipes probably yeah shoot the
pipes like when the zombies are near
them oh that makes sense yeah good news
that one for sure if I use the pistol
can I play it
it's gonna automatically go to it
hopefully
nice 16 teachers oh no I got me got my
feets nice yes liquid nitro
[Music]
ooh thank you too early
[Music]
now you made a good use of it stay down
yo Dix
what is the music still nuts cuz he's
alive what are you a zombie woo
stay down nice I don't think did you
take any damage no well a guy nipped at
my ankles but I'm still fine I did get
nipped though I got nipped in the
Yankees the Yankees
I got nipped on the Mets
I could probably Juke them no I got a
better idea you could probably get these
two to follow you around to the left
side and those [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's
risky cuz then you just run the risk of
getting donated that's when they come at
you from both sides of the donut sure
alright so Juke or donut um try to get
the Juke and then if they don't you just
shotgun to him Oh Oh God
shotgun alright yeah actually wait but
wait they're like I'm still fine yeah
just wait there though just make sure no
one from the left is gonna come at you
but a bunch of Bologna heads
I think these guys are in seven oh here
she comes
you ready yeah I'll [ __ ] you you like
him just dodge that [ __ ] I couldn't I
tried it was tough I struggled oh shut
up
that's ridiculous oh no there's [ __ ]
liquors things out here oh my god no no
I can't I'm almost dead I can't just go
i'ma shoot them but you it's the first
ones not even to knock it back you're
gonna get hit anyways I can't Juke them
they're coming after me you can't be
fast huh no dammit get ready to heal
[Music]
nice I think I should save maybe not it
nah Oh at this save room yes oh yeah
yeah I have them in an hour yet um no I
don't save you'll be fine
you're just I don't even have room for
the same of the other one I don't have a
room for this oh well actually wait hold
on first go to save room anyway offload
some of these uh be that smart
oh no what's that he's gonna come
through the window la ventana oh my god
sorry fellows Martin got freaked out
moths mobs mom OVA vendor moths upset
you alright so left safe room yeah
take the trash and [ __ ] - like where the
fire was sure I can't pick up anything
anyway I'll put this stuff away and then
I'll do it cuz I can't pick it up in no
[Music]
[ __ ] you come on
save room is on the left you should go
for it I hope like if you go into the
safe room and come out he's not gonna be
he will definitely be there nice guitar
just go sorry
that's right whatever I just hope he
doesn't start on the side you remember
that last time we had this happen he
kept starting on the side yeah hopefully
he doesn't well I could save the really
really don't save yet I would I could
also make more shotgun thingies now
might as well what does combining a and
B do anything no
[Music]
so put the crank away you don't need
that yeah just you can get that at the
next save room I like I think I should
heal well here's what I think game you
could leave the door and see where he's
gonna start and then just do a 180 if he
is in front of you and then you can heal
because if he's not gonna be in your way
there's no point in healing or anything
you can escape his rocket launcher he's
gonna chase me yeah but you're pretty
close to the door and then you just keep
running toward the the next safe room I
would rather save at that same room
there's a bunch of zombies in between
you don't heal yet don't say man I don't
feel good about it
just leave quick and then come back in
you could save if he's there I'm telling
you yeah
you should probably check look how close
you're out of the door if he's the [ __ ]
yeah you know how to practice the 180
quick yes just do that
you got alright if he's in your way just
180 to come back in nice it's not nice
because
there's a [ __ ] ton of zombies in here
and the guys gonna show up that's why
I'm upset
yeah I know but just go anyway so
alright so I'm taking a right I'm just
going for that door the bottom one yeah
okay
there's just a lot there's a lot of
zombies in here I think you've got one
in the uptown downtown tell me
family way downtown no more that I think
mmm sounds like a nemesis [ __ ] hear
him just get ready to heal you're fine
you dodging where is he in front of you
somewhere use pearlescent quality use
the if you're worried use the green herb
really quick get out of this and use the
green herb the higher your health uncle
he's gonna hit me with a grenade but go
to stick to this side to the right he's
there he'll with no I know he will Club
me swings with the other arm he'll pick
me up if you go to the witch do you want
to go the other side I'm just saying
he's on the right side of the wall no
he's just completely in the alleyway I'm
saying go to the side where he's not
gonna grab you which is the off arm so
the right side yeah alright Mike okay
well it's up to you I don't know like
really there's one side that heats more
like I took that to the [ __ ] dome
damn I should have exploded yeah all
right yeah hurry the [ __ ] up
I'm fine once you hear the music maybe
he'll but I heard somewhere that he does
not come through the door while I'm
looking at it so I'm safe for now but
still you gotta yeah up there yeah so
I'm gonna take a left and sprint and
then where am I going
so I'm just going through this parking
lot into the right yeah there yeah
damn this dude's a douchebag right I
hated that yeah no I hate you no that
was you hate the nemesis no you're
annoying you bother me
oh [ __ ] crows they're gonna slow me down
yeah thank you
Harry stop Oh
crows things are dicks [ __ ] dicks I'm
hurt
yeah they didn't do anything
I mean they might have gotten closer
wait I need to figure out where I'm
going it's to the left of the truck door
on the right oh you could save here if
you want to I I would recommend not uh
well you do have a lot of alleyways to
get through with a nemesis you might
want to
this might be an escape err no you suck
you actually suck I shouldn't say me
it's gonna be drop or don't ooh do that
pull-up [ __ ] oh my god wait climb up
that maybe that might not that's not the
nemesis
Oh quick Oh God what would have happened
can we check them back the truck now or
do you not know it I wonder what
happened
whew that is for YouTube to decide would
they'd have crushed you kinda look that
up after all right let's get the next
save room you've got a full don't even
save here unless people let's do it
let's do it alright don't waste a ribbon
here I mean it's not wasting you're not
that far but check your map what check
your map stop don't I wish I said go to
the next save room it's so far away
nah you know about this one yeah you got
a full heal or okay okay grabbing and I
like green herb from here something I'm
just trying to think of all right would
it even make a difference is there even
a no matter where we save I think we
might just end it and call it a short
definitely but I'm trying to think of
whether it's even worth trying to get
save the ribbon oh I am saving okay do
that it's just a matter of whether I
save here I save it the next one I know
I get that I'm saying I don't think it
matters really like the only way I
wouldn't matter saving here as opposed
to next if some big event happens in
between here and next if it's just a
normal like getting through zombies then
you're gonna have to do it no matter
what if you save here all cuz I want to
get to here right like this is where I'm
going next right going to here yeah but
we don't know what's gonna happen before
the next saver and we know right now
you're safe like then I should say if
okay just call it a short episode and
then pick up from there do you think
I'll get another event no probably you
might I say we go for it alright I'll go
for it right this is gonna fault
I would pick up an extra great you
already but I did all right so all right
so leave and go up here oh my god
oh we weren't there liquors in here
there was one he's way over there stop
wait dad [ __ ] oh my god [ __ ] I hate when
they walk like this yeah me too
sorry it's gonna take him laughing I
just like I have a little heart
palpitations going on right now
Jill's left
I don't think he's following me anymore
stars like it's been a while yeah I mean
I wouldn't count on it but weird heart
things going on so far going for it was
worth it cuz he didn't take damage yeah
that's what everybody says until they
die totally worth it oh I died not worth
it okay cool
oh I didn't do that great but I didn't
die so it's like you know you got to
take them yeah you gotta you know you
gotta take it as you get it take what
you get
yeah you gotta take what you get I've
only got five ribbons I hope I get more
soon like I'm doing okay I think right
yeah
yes yes on the penultimate episode of
resident evil 3 I kill the nemesis see
you next time
that's it
but